division and bitterness anger and
illness a presidential campaign like no
other is about to come to an
end at stake the destiny of the united
states and with it
the future of the world tonight america
decides
florida has been this pivotal state for
decades
so what is happening well we can look at
the numbers come over here and let's
have a look
in short it is very tight but actually
leaning
towards donald trump
[Applause]
the trump campaign very much likes what
they see in the day of
me a little bit voting why we are uh
sort of out of precipice in many ways
um for democracy this is just becoming
more and more of a nail-biter as we go
into the night
and there it is the poles have now
closed across
not
[Music]
well it's available hotting up here
dermott and uh democrat voters in the
bar i'm out at downtown phoenix
um are really really exciting we are
projecting
that donald trump will take oh i will
retain
ohio yeah and i'm getting some messages
from the trump camp they're feeling very
positive
no destruction
nothing of that sort it's going to be a
nail-biting
few days here people certainly pacing
themselves here in pittsburgh tonight
most have gone home knowing that they
won't necessarily
hear this result until as late as friday
we can now project that donald trump
will win florida we believe we're on
track to win this election
we're going to have to be patient until
we uh
the hard work of tallying the votes is
finished and it ain't over until every
vote is counted
every ballot is counted donald trump has
just tweeted
we are up big they the democrats are
trying to steal the election in iowa
we are projecting for donald trump biden
we are projecting we'll take the states
of minnesota
this is a fraud on the american public
this is an embarrassment to our country
so we'll be going to
the u.s supreme court we want
all voting to stop we don't want them to
find
any ballots at four o'clock in the
morning and add them to the list
okay it's it's a very sad
it's a very sad moment to me this is a
very sad moment and
we will win this and as far as i'm
concerned we already have one